foreign
[Music]
oh thanks I
love you are the most amazingly
beautiful demon I have ever seen
soul of the forest wow
why have you trenched paths here strange
lady offered me a big reward to find a
special leaf
in the forest behind the dark Mountain
[Music]
did you find a tree
and where is this peasant loser there
[Music]
you could play your music for me do you
realize how illegal this is
[Music]
this human is no different than all the
others
he will betray you
[Music]
incredible
Lucas was it the source of life
there's only one way to stop this evil
strike first
[Music]
go and never return
how no matter where you look
[Music]
you look mistake I made once
in the forest alike
fire and hatred
Without End
[Music]
ing
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
they must be migrating migration what a
stupid idea okay you're impossible
because I found a safe place for us to
live
I want us to get out and see the world
[Music]
fight me if I want my young child In
Harm's Way for no reason except a chance
at a Caribbean vacation I don't want to
miss out in life because you're afraid
to leave this pond
hey
around me
why are we the only Birds heading this
way
peace
I promise adventure and this is exactly
what I promised
what is
it's you with Laurence on top
can we and you're old enough to do it in
the sky now we have a number two
situation oh but it's gross every bird
does it in the sky
we're not Landing there is no way we're
Landing
when Mallard do it now or we leave
without you okay okay
we are completely lost we're trying to
get to Jamaica I love birds it's this
way well we are not flying through this
crazy death trap of a city just stay
close to me and everything will be all
right
oh
I'm okay yeah no I'm okay we can do this
maybe you don't stick too close
when our world is threatened
one team
ready to launch does he say lunch uh no
I said launch
[Music]
whoa
it's giving off some kind of energy
I didn't do it
no way this September I think we've got
super powers
and that's why I wear a hard hat
[Music]
I'm a wrecking ball
look at your paws
now the clumsy pup shoots Fireballs out
of his paw
Paw Patrol
with just a little bit extra
how about
the mighty pups
supposed to be my superpowers
I'll take them one by one
oh my goodness I could talk
so much to say give me that
he looks different than I remember
can you go up against one of us
you go up against all of us
now that we're super I'm never gonna get
to sleep well you're probably more tired
than you
oh you've got to be kidding me
[Music]
imagine a place
well wishes come true
for your heart's desire can become a
reality
what if I told you that
that you have to do
is give your wish
[Music]
I wish
what was that
[Music]
it didn't work when does the magic
happen huh
I'm talking I am talking who knew my
voice would be this low
[Music]
foreign
what I mean let's get Bridget and
Crystal married yeah oh cause that would
be weird if we got married yeah wow
oh boy that was a crazy bachelor party
uh Cloud guy don't feel so good
tiny diamond you make the cutest Little
Flower Boy come on Daddy I'm the cutest
Little Flower Man
dearly beloved we are gathered here
today
I'm John Dory branches long lost brother
what Grandma call me
you're the guy from Grow Zone we were
just listening to them
but that's all in the past
ever told me you had a secret brother
correction used to be my brother
my brothers walked out on me and never
came back Branch we're out of sync we've
gone from Boys to Men and now there's
only one direction for us to go the back
streets
Branch it's time to find the rest of our
brothers and get the band back together
bro we're gonna have the best family
reunion ever Rosa 2.0 Frozone reunion
grows on Here We Grow Again Frozone
where's they bro I don't know we're
gonna find them
all right tiny Bread's Poppy and this
random dude on another Musical Adventure
oh hey tiny you see that button right
there oh you mean the button is taking
every fiber about being not depressed
oh
[Music]
wow too much hustle is a thing huh look
at that
[Music]
for centuries we have called out to the
universe
looking for answers
in 2024
the universe
calls back
bring us your lead
[Music]
[Applause]
hi can you hear me honey now is a really
bad time okay
bye
I love you I love you I love you
[Music]
this is new
whoa please State the name of your home
world uh Earth welcome leader of Earth
we are the United Advanced species of
the Universe I think there's been a
mistake you're not the leader of Earth
sorry for the mix-up commence memory
wise no wait
I am the leader of Earth why is your
voice different uh I've always talked
like this since I was a kid which I'm
obviously not anymore but yes I run the
planet the trial of Earth can proceed
uh-oh until then as you say on Earth
okay bye I love you okay okay
the talk of the communiverse if Mom
could see me now I know what you mean I
ate my mother at Birth but in moments of
great success I regret it that's a thing
for your species no just a me thing
everyone was shocked
[Music]
boys where have you been
we're just running errands that's it
oh look we're really sorry Spooner some
of the guys wanted to get pizza and I
tried to talk him out of it you ratted
us out hey don't use that word that way
I mean
hey guys if we weren't monsters that
were shunned by society and we could do
what we wanted
what would you guys do go to high school
maybe get a girlfriend can you imagine
that not likely
[Music]
I want to know everything about you our
dad is definitely not a giant rat that
makes me feel like he's a rat
police are baffled by the recent crime
wave led by a Superfly nobody's ever
seen his face why because he kills
everyone who does
no not cool a bit cool we think I'm
super fun and then everyone will think
we're cool
he's making a deal tonight under the
Brooklyn Bridge
I can't believe there are other mutants
you want to roll with us
humans are never gonna like us
so we gonna let the mutants rule the
Earth
people's they got to go okay um sort of
a twist
can't stop him we gotta try
six in the morning police at my dump
my son Michelangelo you have hearts
Donatello you have wisdom Rafael you
have bravery and Leonardo honored
enough talk I dream about fighting every
night you've got a rage
not a problem
[Music]
all right that's a girl
oh my God okay
not sure if you knew who I am but I'm
about to rule the world
wow uh yay but there's one problem
there's a human has a mustache just like
you
do you think I know every human being
with a mustache wearing an identical
outfit with a hat with the letter of his
first name on it because I don't
Bowser is coming
together we
are going to stop that monster how look
at us we're
oh I got this no problem
our big adventure begins now ah get it
out get it out get it off
it's a huge Universe out there
with a lot of galaxies
they're all counting on us
no pressure
[Music]
foreign
Ty the women in our family had the
mighty power to turn into giant Kraken
what now Ruby you're a princess
I think
I am having a panic attack
okay Ruby have you completely totally
ordinary day you got this
[Music]
I feel like a freak out I just want to
be Ruby Gilman normal teenager oh boo
where's the fun in that you have powers
beyond your imagination
you are the protector of all the oceans
creatures it's up to you to stop the
evil mermaids but people love mermaids
of course they do people are stupid
show me how to use my power are you
ready
see what you're capable of
body armor
almost
it's time to go big
still on for a tutoring session later
right oh
anything for my algebra you do what no I
mean bro
algebra like you're my brother you're my
math brother
I think I like the first one better
after all she's been through she's
trying to make up for what happened to
her you mean how Wesker brainwasher and
made her come after us no one's blaming
Jill for that no one
what's up Jill
I can do that
doctor and Taylor yeah yeah we need him
in custody ASAP I checked the DNA we got
from a bite wound on an orca carcass had
a strain of t-virus in it you're kidding
I found the connection between the folks
that were infected they all visited
Alcatraz recently
well Dr Taylor
it's time we debuted our
creation
they turn fast and without being bitten
I'm Rebecca what do you want me to tell
them someone accessed the dod server
they managed to steal data on Leon Jill
Chris and Claire you think this might
have something to do with the operon now
most likely
I'm going to use my virus to clean the
Slate Dylan
nothing more than pause
I can't be good
yeah
[Music]
excuse me
he's all yours
we're at the final stage now that there
is no justice
[Music]
let's do it all of us
definitely going on vacation after this
my name is Miles Morales I'm Brooklyn's
one and only Spider-Man and things are
going great oh yeah you're supposed to
be here all right whatever whatever
so are you like a cow or a Dalmatian I
am the spot
that's not funny
don't don't do that
miles's grades are pretty good A and AP
Physics that's my little man and a B in
Spanish what
miles
come to you and I think you know it
[Music]
wanna get out of here oh when
so wait a minute there's an elite crew
with all the best spider people in it
who's the new guy danger this is
unbelievable this is the lobby
Miguel O'Hara the whole thing with his
idea what's the guy I gotta do to join
this spider team you you can never be
part of this don't even get me started
on Doctor Strange and a little nerd back
on Earth 1999-99 come on go easy on the
kid he had a terrible teacher Peter
files you have a baby
I'll take it from here
miles being Spider-Man is a sacrifice
you have a choice between saving one
person
and saving every world
send me home I can't do that I can do
both Spider-Man always always what about
Uncle Ben if not for Uncle Ben most of
us wouldn't be here
you can't run forever dude I can't lose
one more friend
I have no idea what are you doing
everyone keeps telling me how my story
is supposed to go
I'm gonna do my own thing
stop Spiderman
[Music]
and then I looked at my uncle and ah let
me guess he died
[Music]
meet the residents of element City
air usually has their head in the clouds
oh my new jacket Earth can be a little
seedy nothing weird going on here just a
little pruning water is always getting
into something
oh
and fire as ordered we run a little hot
[Music]
this shop is dream of our family someday
it'll all be yours but we all live by
one simple rule
[Music]
a pipe squished me all out of shape
that's better oh
so you've never left firetown sorry
buddy elements don't mix
hey plus my dad would boil you alive why
does anyone get to tell you what you can
do in your life
why do they even have these yes who
knows
whoa
[Applause]
dear guy you live here it's my mom's
place we got two kids that are swimming
around here somewhere
I've been trying to fill my father's
shoes
I never once asked what I wanted to do
write this Dad those are too hot I love
hot food
[Music]
[Applause]
you see he likes it
Legion Academy if you want it you could
train here think of them as the Futures
Justice League
it's all great to meet you I'm monel
this is the rest of the academy trainees
are the front lines administering
Justice and preventing War
still the control
Brainiac
I am not going to let you hurt anyone
else with her abilities that makes her a
threat I don't like what you're implying
still have no idea where the rest of the
Legion is I've seen the dark circle come
on we don't have very much time it's up
to us so let's go be heroes
foreign
chase our new home
past every owner of this house has been
forced to flee by the ghost of Simon to
canterville
I don't think you're that scary at all
oh ghost or no ghost this family are
here to stay I hated here okay good talk
Henry Fitz Humphrey we used to own the
place until the ghost drove us out
really I need your help to scare my
parents out of here
[Music]
do you mind sir
this is my house
[Applause]
oh I'm a ghost who cannot haunt Hello
Ghost wait
I failed you we can't just give up
delightful of you to call on us forever
and
this is not funny
so how many ghosts have you actually
caught technically this will be my first
this way
that's a cupboard
[Music]
I want to see the world have Adventures
Henry
[Music]
slow down your Killers you're a goat
you're already dead oh yes
hello there inspector Sun world famous
detective
New York All Aboard careful with that
relax sweetie it's our honeymoon tickets
Mr guilty it's pronounced
guilty it's French
[Music]
who is she that's baroness Black Widow
Arabella kill top Dr spinderthoff
inspector's son listen I'm the
wealthiest bug on this flying boat I
believe my life is in danger with all
due respect doctor collage is not a
dangerous hobby I want you watching my
back what I believe is you have an
overactive imagination and a dangerous
wife
[Music]
Sonic we need you it's been a murder
we're not looking for one killer but two
three
do I hear four four it was her someone
clearly doesn't want you looking into
this Bugsy case
I know someone tried to off me
don't panic Arabella you're putting us
both in terrible danger save me son
let's go partner
Stop in the Name of the law
I am on my honeymoon and uh you got a
little something on your uh never mind
foreign
[Music]
thank you I'm gonna be the champ
I just want to race
a silk road rally oh it's gonna be epic
building a trophy case I mean you
haven't even won yet but I will you seem
pretty confident you're gonna win
willing to stick a bet on it you're the
one who's supposed to be going to be
doing the beating of me
I laugh at the idea
[Laughter]
why the long face kid kinda have to sort
of race the Silk Road Rally that the
race is no holds bar 200 miles per hour
for four days to raid across unforgiving
terrain against the craziest drivers in
the world
I know how am I gonna beat the best
racer in the world alright kid listen
you got everything you need but you and
me together
there ain't nothing we can do
whoa okay let's see what you got let's
go
this is crazy
you see that guy's car if I had a car
like that cars don't win races
[Music]
I'm in way over my head I can help you
but no questions asked you would do that
but why okay there was two questions
right off the line see you tomorrow
[Music]
for almost 20 years I've been moving
these antennae around in vain to make
contact with outer space as soon as you
arrived the signal started coming
I believe that you
are a human antenna
human antenna what is your status over
I got a dog
[Music]
what's your name my name is Obama oh
crap
oh crap where are we going now little
darling come on follow me oh no this is
not happening
did we go to Wild Splat Walt this is
Obama
uh no my name's actually Brittany
Brittany
Walt she crashed with her spaceship and
a man came and took it and now she can't
get home oh my word that's Robert is he
a bad man no no he's not a bad guy but
his brother is we will finally know the
answer does life exist in outer space
and more importantly can it be stuffed
we need to get to the spaceship little
antenna before he does we gotta hurry I
love that kind of enthusiasm let's go
thank you
oh
let's see what to do about this
hang on Teddy
I can see the whole world wonderful
I promise you we'll get your spaceship
tomorrow huh
would you like a cup sure thanks maybe
just half a cup
[Music]
[Laughter]
thank you
[Music]